じゃあよろしくお願いします
今日は業の2番目のセット
業はこの 4つ  4つのセットの 4つに分けて16種類に分けているんです
で これで2番目のセット
この4つなんです ガルカ
アーサンナ アーチンナ
カタッターという業の4つ
で この4つで どんな角度で分けてますかというと
この小 あ 結生 人が亡くなって
人ではなくて生命がなくなってどこかに生まれ変われると
その時はその生まれ変わる結生するとき
どんなカルマが働いてくれるかという
その結生のカルマなんですね
で この前のセットで説明したジャナカカンマ
そのジャナカカンマ自体を 4つに分けてるだけ
ジャナカカンマっていうのは冷静後
冷静後 これ全部冷静後の4種類なんです
はい で ガルカ ガルカ まあいつでもカンマという言葉を使いますけど
ガルカカンマ アーサンナカンマ
アーチンナカンマ カタッターカンマ
で ガルカというのはすごく重いという意味なんですね
で まあ重いという意味もあるし
尊いという意味もあるし
まあその両方の意味でパーリ語でガルという言葉を使っているんです
ですから 重いカンマか尊いカンマかどっちでもということで
もし人が もしどんな生命でも
この重いという重業という重いカルマを一つ行っているならば
その人が亡くなったら確実に次にそのカンマの結果
そのカルマの結果として生まれ変われるということなんです
だから行ったカンマ自体
行為自体がすごい重いと
あまりにも重いんだから
確実にそのカルマが次に結果が出してくれると
で 不善 不善の場合は仏教で言っているのは
この母親父親を殺したならば
それは重いカルマなんですね
ガルカカンマなんです
もし人が自分の母親か父親か殺したならば
必ずも次の 死んだら次に必ずしもその悪いカルマが悪い影響を与えちゃうんですね
だから決まってる場所に必ずも行く
ですから 他の言葉で言うならば
母親父親を殺した人がいるならば
その人がもうどんな良いことをしていたっても
世の中で もう次に死んじゃったらどこに行くかということだけはしっかり言えるということなんです
それ母親父親を殺すことだけじゃなくて
聖者ですか 阿羅漢ですか
悟った人々を殺すことも同じなんですね
悟った方々 それからブッダですね
お釈迦様とかね そういう正覚者
ブッダに怪我させたら
なぜそこに怪我したらと言うんですかというと
ブッダを殺すことはできないんです
で 普通のア羅漢になった悟った人を殺そうと思えば殺されるんです
それでも死にはしないんです
で 悟った人がやっぱり自分の意思で心を止まる
止まるんですね ですから
でも体このぐらいにしてすることはできるんです
ですから どうせその体バラバラにしちゃったら
もう生きていられませんだからね
死ななくちゃなくならなくちゃいけないんです
ですから もう殺したことになっちゃうし
ブッダを 正覚者を殺すことは不可能なんです
で これはもう生命の すべての生命のレベルを乗り越えているんだから
まあそんなあっちこっちにいる人を殺すことはできない
せいぜいできることは
まあ怪我するぐらいのことなんです
ですから デーヴァダッタというお釈迦様の親戚なんですけど
まあ回 回も殺そうと企んでやったんだけど
できなかったんです その代わりお釈迦様に怪我させたんですね
それでデーヴァダッタがアチーリという地獄に落ちたんだそうです
で そこで両親殺すことと
そこで二つと阿羅漢殺すこと三つと
あのお釈迦様の まあお釈迦様だけではなくて
その時代で現れてるブッダの体に怪我することで
四種の重い罪がありますね
それよりもっと重い罪っていうのは
こので サンガとしてのお釈迦様のね
ブッダの弟子たちが出家して
輪を持って ものすごい固い絆でお互いに約束いっぱいやって
もう一つの組織として行動しているんですね
ですから これはすごいしっかりしたシステムなんです
サンガのシステムというのは
どんな国にいても どんな人間であろうが
そういうことなく みんな同じ決まりの中で
その同じ決まりを守って
一つのボディとして 一つのシステムとして行動しているんです
そこですごい力を持ってるし
個人個人で威張ろうとはしないんですね
個人で私は開祖様になってやるぞという気持ちは
まあこのお釈迦様の弟子たちの間では全くないんです
自分たちがただサンガのメンバー一人だけですよ
それで一人メンバーとしてはいろいろ活動はするんだけど
私こそ偉いぞとか ああだこうだということは全然ありえないし
しないし ですから それで仏教というのはとても純粋に後の人々に伝えることができたんですね
仏教はなかなかこのいろんな国々で崩してしまった
崩れてしまったんだけど
初期仏教のやり方は この南の国々の方でなぜきちんと守られているかというと
このサンガのシステムがあるんだからなんです
ですから それ壊そうといろんな人々がいろんな工夫しているんです
今も工夫しているんです
で 例えばタイにしたっても
タイは仏教 まあ九十パーセント仏教徒ですけど
新聞なんかではいろんな批判したり
もう何とかして もうお互いにもう別れて
もうバラバラにしてやろうという企みは明確にあるんです
で そういうまあ新聞作ったりするのはほとんどの違うグループの人々だからね
で ある日ニュースでなんかフロントページ表紙の写真出して作って出してるんです
あのタイのお坊さんがなんかプレイボーイの雑誌を持って
このヘッドフォンにスチールをかけて
なんかロック音楽を聴いてるというような感じでね
普通の人々がすごくそれに怒ったんだけど
後で探してみたら まあ誰かの俳優さんにお金払って
そういう風に写真撮って
今のタイのお坊さんたちの生活はそんなもんだよと
すごい長い記事なんです
ニュース記事なんです
で まあそういう風に このとにかくこの
もし本当にお坊さんがそういうことしたなら
お坊さんたちは知ってるし
お坊さんたちがもう何者か
その人は 探したところでまあもう顔を見たら同じ大臣だからね
まあ普通の俳優さんということをわかって
で 大体まあそういうことをなぜやっているかというと
やっぱりこのまあ このサンガを通して
このきちんとシステムをきちんと守って
このお釈迦様だけ開祖様であって
他の人々はただお釈迦様の弟子たちであって
教えをみんなに教えてあげることだけですよ
そういう風にあるんだから
仏教は純粋に守られるし
ですからとにかくそれを壊さない限り
仏教の力はなかなかなくならないので
まあそれでもいろいろトラブルはあっちこっちから槍刺されると怪我はしますけど
で その怪我の収まり たまたま化膿したりもしますけど
まだまだ死んではいないんです
で お釈迦様は昔から教え子だな
このサンガの今日は お互いにすごく仲良く
一つの兄弟のようにいる
このシステムだけはすごい大事に守りなさい
もし誰かがその調和を破れるように企んだら
まあそれはまあ思い積みです
なぜならば 全ての人々に解脱の道を閉ざしますから
それ人殺しよりは重い罪なんです
で それは何回も起きたんです
この仏教 お坊さんたちがね
戒律決まりしっかり守らなくちゃいけないと決めた時
部派仏教だといって 昔もう別れてしまったんですね
あなた方とは一緒に行動しませんと
で 別れてしまって 自分たちで好き勝手に戒律を作ったり
改良したりする 一旦改良したら
それでサンガのメンバーでならなくなっちゃうんです
ですから 初期仏教では大乗仏教の人々
お坊さんだと 本当は本当の正直なところ認めない
ただの在家だと いくら悪口を言われたってても気にしない
向こうは 向こうから見れば
それを法律的に見ると
もうお坊さんじゃないんです
なぜならば この戒律を放棄したんだから
戒律改良しようとか 新しく新しく入れ替えようと思ったら
その時点でもう自分たちがお釈迦様から受け継いだ戒律を放棄しているんです
自分の先生をね 先生を放棄しちゃったら
もうそのグループの仲間ではないんだと
ですから いろいろ部派仏教が出てきて
それからまあ在家の人々が集めて大乗仏教を作って
その方々はまた自分たちが仏教だとまた言い張ったりしてやってはいますけど
初期仏教の立場から見れば
もう何のことなく 普通の在家の人々なんです
そういうことでどうなったかというと
大勢の人々に仏教の道がなくなったんですね
大勢の人々は だから仏教といいながら
しきたりと儀式とかご利益とかなんとかとかやるだけで
でなんかドラマみたいなね
まあ修行とかなんとか見たらドラマやってるんです
もう別に見たらもうちゃんと時計で決まってる時間で起きる
決まってる時間で寝て
決まってる時間で決まってる時間以内で食べたりとかね
で そんなものは別にもうただのドラマですから
そういうことだけに  なってしまったんです
まあそういうわけで この父親を両親殺すことは重い罪だと
サンガを分裂させることを重い罪だというと
どういうことかというと
その意味でサンガ分裂させちゃったら
その人々はもう人を殺すより重い罪を起こしてしまっちゃうんですね
だから人々は誰の話を聞けばいいかわからなくなっちゃうんです
そういうことでいろいろ異論があるかもしれませんだけど
でも同じグループの中でいろんな異論があっちゃうと
お互いに喧嘩しないで
経典に合わせて それはもう研究はするんです
誰の意見が正しいかないかと
それで意見が間違っているということになった人々は
もう潔く認めるんです
それはもうサンガの決まりなんです
私はこういうふうに思っているよという自由は誰にでもあります
それで他のお坊さんたちが言って
ちょっと待ってください
お釈迦様がおっしゃった共有共有経典から見ると
あなた言っていることは違うんじゃないかと
それでサンガがお坊さんたちがそれは違いますよと決めたならば
あの人が潔くそれを認めなくちゃいけない
それを認めないと その人は破門するんです
もうメンバーではありません
ですから まあ結構自由なことは自由なんです
自由ですけど お釈迦様の教えを崩すことはもう認めてない
それ別に当たり前のことで
仏教徒でいて仏教を崩すぞというのは意味がないんだから
キリスト教を信じなきゃキリスト教になる必要はないんです
私はキリスト教ですけど
キリストの教えを信じませんというのは意味がないんです
ですから サンガでやるならば
お釈迦様がおっしゃった言葉を信じるのは当たり前の話ですから
そういうふうに思い込みは一つあります
それに加えてまたあります
この何ですか アマさんを犯すこと
出家しているアマさんを犯すことも大変な思い込みで
確実にその人々も地獄に行ってしまっちゃう
もう一つは この強力なこの邪見持っていることなんですね
いわゆる心は閉じて 自分思っている意見しか聞かない
邪見を作るのはすごい簡単なんです
で 人間というのはもともと論理的じゃないんだからね
みんな威張ってるだけで論理的だと思ってね
論理的じゃないんです
ですから このこれこそ素晴らしいんですよと言ったら
そうですか それをもう信じ込んじゃうんです
それから聞くものは全部あれに対照して比べて聞こうと勉強しようとしているんです
だから私は仏教喋るとこでいつでもトラブルになるのはそういうわけなんです
大乗仏教で決まってる基準
尺度があって もうその目で初期仏教は何を言っちゃってるんですかと聞きたくなるんですね
私は喋ると なんかこの尺度で測れなくなっちゃうと怒るんですね
で 何を言ってるんですかと
こんなここまで世界でたくさん人々が信じていることに反対しているんですかと
で怒っちゃうんですね
で 私もまあこの人々はもう完全な無知だから話にならないんだと思って
ものすごくなんとかすごい混乱させて帰る
もう別に親切にしようとはしない
もう永遠にもう混乱しなさい
で 一つの例なんですけど
まあ浄土仏教っていうのは自分だけのことを考えているんだと
だから浄土仏教と言うんだと
大乗仏教っていうのは一切の衆生の悟りを考えているんだと
だから大乗仏教だと それで決めて決め
決めつけてくれ で あなた方の浄土仏教の教えは何ですかと
それで僕はその基準を知っているんだから
教えてくれるんだから
先に で そうですね 我々の修行っていうのは
これ あの まあこうやって心を清らかにすることであって
己の心を清らかにすることであって
でもそれは他人がなければ成り立たないんだと
だからもう他人に対して限りない慈悲を持って行動することで
己の心清らかになるんだと
ですから 私だけ悟ってやるぞと
他の人に教えてあげませんと思ったら
その人は悟りませんと
自分も修行しながら 他の方々も苦しみからなくなってほしいと
もし自分が分かったならば
みんなにも教えて あげますと
そういうふうな気持ちでやるんだと
ですから この自分だけのことを考える自己主義でも利他行でもなく
ちょっと違う道だよと
だから怒られる 何言ってるんですかと
この今までずっと認めている定期否定してるんですかと
であの当たってくるんですね
僕は聞くのはその敵誰が作ったんですかと
お釈迦様が作ったんですか？誰が作ったんですかと
はっきり言ってくださいと
作った人は見つからないんですね
あんた方は勝手に作ったんだからって
そうなるわけじゃないんだと
あなたは私に角二つ付いてるよとあなた言っても
だからあなた言うんだから
私に角があるわけじゃないんだと
だから 大乗の人々は我々は浄土仏教だと言ったんだからって
これは浄土仏教になるわけないんですね
よくも人のことをけなすんだとね
ですから 仏教ではね 他人をけなすと
それでも仏教ではないと
とんでもない 私も他人をけなしちゃいますけど
まあとにかく混乱させるんですよ
目的は 僕の目的はとにかく混乱させるんだと
で やっぱりそういう話をすると
いつでもそれ基準を持って話を聞くとぶつかっちゃうんですね
もう将来にはもう大きな穴が掘ったってことなんですね
信じるのは簡単なんです
麻原こそ唯一のブッダだということを信じるのは簡単なんです
信じたらそれでその人の全部将来は終わりなんです
ですから これこういうのは邪見に落ちないように心を大事に
自由な状態 物事を客観的に見られる状態守らなくちゃいけない
まあそれでも絶対的な邪見もいろいろありますが
全部地獄に行くというわけじゃないんです
で 理性がある人はまあ論理的に考えて間違ってるんだと分かったら
それはもうなんとなく何のことなく捨てちゃいますからね
これ絶対的だとという立場をとってるのは
もうどうしようもないですね
この戒姆主義とかはね
まあそういう恐ろしい邪見のグループに入れてるんですね
なぜというと 例えばこの
まあそういう邪見自体も何か根拠がないんだから
論理的に見て成り立ってないんだから
崩すのはできないんですね
論理的に作った意見だったら
たとえ間違っていても教えてあげたら
あ なるほど この論理間違ってたんだと
とわかるでしょう 論理ない場合は教えるもないんですね
例えば人は死んじゃったらそれで終わりと思う
何もないんだと 行為には何の結果もないんだと
言ったらどんな論理があってそう言いますかと
そういう論理がないんですね
すべては神様が作ったよという人々いるでしょうに
論理はどこにありますかと
論理がないんですね その結論に至ったこの論理的な考え方
プロセスはない だからもう手上げ
もし人がこういうこういうわけで神様がいるぞと言ったならば
その人は正義なんです
なぜならば その人は論理を持ってるんです
そうすると あ その論理は本当に正しいと考えているか
ちゃんと比較しているかないかっていうことを誰でも検討できますから
そのようにこの思い罪が五つじゃなくて七つぐらいあります
それからそれ悪い方で
いい方で言うならば サマーディ瞑想して禅定を作っている人々
禅定があると第一禅定から八までありますから
それはすごい重いカルマなんですね
その場合は重いというよりは尊いカンマ
業なんですね その人々は亡くなったら
次の生まれで確実にそのカルマにふさわしいどこかの梵天の次元に生まれ変わっちゃう
まあ大体この伝統的な説明は
まあそんなもんなんですね
で あの この まあ一般的に言うと
この重いカルマっていうのは
やっぱり人が起こす重い罪なんですね
だから重い罪を起こしたら
まあそれは簡単には忘れられません
ですから やっぱりずっと心の中でも生き生きしているんです
自分がもうやった ものすごい悪いことをしたならば
ですから ほとんどその場合はもう
例えば人を殺したりしたならば
それで人が逃げて逃げてるかもしれませんだけど
一生 一生逃げてはいるんだけど
毎日なぜ自分が逃げてるんですかと
ということはいつでも心にあるんですね
名前も変えて 顔も変えて
整形までして いろいろあの
工夫しているかもしれません
それでも捕まる時がすぐありますけど
で だからといって その人には毎日もうそれは忘れることはできないんです
もしその人捕まえてそれなりに法律で裁いたところで
まあ自分がそれなりの罰を受けたんだからというふうに
なんとなくちょっとリラックスすることはできます
じゃあせっかく捕まえて
もうもう判決ね もらって
それでその人それなりの
あの 償いをするでしょうに
刑務所で償いとは言えませんだけど
それでその人々だったら
やっぱり じゃあ一旦もう殺人として認めたし
まあこれからどうすればいいかという
これからのこと刑務所で考えるでしょ
ですから 別に隠そうともしないし
なんであんたこっちには私は人を殺しちゃったんだからということを平気で言えるようになっちゃうし
そういう風になっちゃうと
あんまりこの悩みの種にならないんですね
それなりのことをやってるんだと
ですから 人殺しなんかしたら確実に地獄に行くということは言いにくい
でも殺したのは自分の母親だったら
いくら刑務所にいたっても
あの悲しみというか あの悩みというのは消えないんですね
世の中見れば見るほど
自分の悩みが増していく
いっちゃうんですね なぜならば
大人になればなるほど
母親っていうのはどれほど大事に子供を育てるかっていうのは
どこを見ても見られるでしょうに
動物を見ても 動物の母親たちがどれほどもう真剣に大事に子供を守って育てるかと
見えちゃいますから ですから
ものすごいもう自分のことを
もう悩みもなんともちゃいけないんですね
それはなかなか避けられないんです
そういうわけで 両親殺すことは確実な重い罪になる
人殺すことはそんなに重い罪だとは言ってない
ここで重いというのは亡くなって次の生まれのこと
人が死ぬ瞬間でどんなカルマで生まれ変わるかというと
まず重業を起こしているならば
その業によって生まれると
重業いくつかやっているならばどうなるんでしょうかね
例えばデーヴァダッタは
2つやりましたから お釈迦様怪我することもしましたし
サンガの分裂もしましたし
その場合はこの重業を 3つぐらいやっちゃったら
その重業は最後にじゃんけんをするとか
そういうことはないんですけど
どっちにしましょうかとかね
だいたいそちらの中でも順番があるんです
まあまあ どうせ父親殺すよりは母親殺すのは罪が多い
重い 一般的には なぜならば
母親はもう本当に危ない
ひどい命をもう危機にさらされて子供を産んだり育てたりするんだから
それは一つ それから 父親と母親比べてみたら
どちらの方が徳が高いかというと
そちらの方の罪が重い
例えば父親がすごい徳の高い人
ものすごい心ができている人だったら
もうその父親を殺す その父親も母親も殺したならば
父親のカルマが重いんだから
それは先に出ちゃうんです
ですから 両親の場合はそういう順番
普通の人だったら母親の方が重いし
父親の方が軽いし で その二人が心がすごくできている人だったら
もうそれでまた順番変える
両親殺すよりは阿羅漢殺す罪が大きい
それよりはブッダのブッダに怪我することはもっと重い罪である
それより重いのはこのサンガの分裂です
ですから デーヴァダッタはサンガを分裂させたんだから
それで地獄の道なんです
で お釈迦様に怪我したんだけど
その後お釈迦様に会ったりはしたんです
殺そうとして それでもお釈迦様はもう別に何も思いませんだからもう来てやったり
あっちこっちいろいろ行動したりはしていたんです
そこでまた開き直って
もうこれでこの人を殺そうとしたってのも殺せないと
じゃあもう弟子たちを連れて
自分が別に別な宗教を作るぞと思って
お釈迦様にそれを報告するんですね
今日からは私たちは別に行動するんだと言って帰る
で 帰っているとお釈迦様は彼の後ろ姿を見て
あの人はもう二度と私の顔は見えません
あの人に と言うんです
で そこであの死にかけちゃってね
あの血が吐くようになって
病気になって で 最後のところになったら
またお釈迦様に会いたくなったんですね
死にかけているんだから
それで弟子たちに命令して連れてきなさいって言ったら
弟子たち断ったんです
あなたあれほどのことをやってまだ会いたいんですか？言ったらもう我々にはもうその人の弟子たちだからね
私たちにはいけません
と言ったら もうあなた方は関係ないんだと
連れてきなさいと で 連れてきたんです
で 連れてくるなという
あの なんていうか 喝で連れてくるんです
連れてくるという話が聞いたんだけど
お釈迦様にメッセージ入ったら
お釈迦様はでも彼には私に会うことはできないんだと
理由はサンガの分裂したんだからね
分かれたから それ以上はもう私には会えませんと
会えなかったんです 途中で亡くなって
地獄にそのまま吸い込まれたんだというふうに言ってましたけどね
そこは重い罪 それよりこの尼僧を犯すことはもっと重いと言っている
その場合は尼僧はやっぱり悟っている場合
[背景音楽]で 邪見 邪見持ってると
まあ順番は分かりませんだけど
邪見持っているともう決まってるんだから
行くとこはもう最初からもうすごいしっかりと
ですから 自分で決まってるんだからね
やっぱり他の父親 母親を殺してやったっても
そんなもう関係ないんだと
という気持ちでいるんだから
邪見の方が細部に行動するんです
番目は で 大体みんな みんなではなくて
世の中でこの銃後を起こす人っていうのはもう稀な人々ですけどね
で なかなか聞こえない話なんですけどね
まあまあ 僕は日本に来るまでは
この母親父親を殺すという話っていうのは
本当は世の中であり得ないことだと
それぐらい思っていたんです
自分の国を出る前までは
そんなことをお釈迦様おっしゃっても
世の中じゃありえないんだと
いくら喧嘩したっても
やっぱり両親は両親だからというふうに思っていたんだけど
やっぱりもう社会にいろいろ入ってみたら
もう結構あることで驚いちゃったんだけどね
で あそこまでできるということはもうすごいことなんですね
もう人を殺すことにしたっても
すごい心が恐ろしくなってないとできないし
そこで毎日顔を合わせて一緒にご飯食べて一緒に寝ている
もう小さい時からでも
自分がね もう育てられた人に手を上げるということは
ちょっと想像できないんですね
どこかで何か間違ってるんで
それは 喧嘩したっても
まあ口喧嘩以上あるのはちょっとおかしいと思います
まあ口喧嘩くらいはいくらか認めたってもね
僕らもだいたい自分の国でもね
自分の両親に対していろいろ文句言ったりする場合ありますけど
でも面と向かって言わないです
ちょっと文句ばっかり裏で他の人に
父親に文句言いたいんだったら
母親に言って 母親一緒に母親に文句を言う
まあそれぐらいのことで
もう面と向かっては言わない
黙ってる お互いの意見が合わない場合は
大体お互いにあまりもう口をきかないで
もうもうあんたはあんたが勝手にやりなさいと
私こっちというふうに
やっぱり自由にしてあげちゃうんですね
ですから この まあとにかくそれはもう我々のね
現代社会 あまりにも欲望でね
行動しているんだから
まあ人間を愛することや人間を大事に考えることは全く消えちゃったんだからね
人間よりはお金大事ですし
社会的 立場が大事でしょうし
家っていうものは大事でしょうし
ですから まあ完全に狂ってるんだからね
そういう現象が出てくるだろうと思いますね
だからといって 例えば父親が自分の息子を殺したりするのは銃後にならないんですよ
それは殺人である 普通に
そこでもしかするとね
私は言ってはいけませんだけど
この普通の人のよりは
例えば自分が自分の息子やら娘やら殺すんだったら
それなりのわけがあるんですね
別に殺したくないんだから
本来は 他の人からお金を奪おうと思って殺さなくちゃっていうこと出てくるかもしれませんだけど
顔見られたら大変だ ああだこうだとかね
でも自分の子供の場合はそんなことは全くもないし
殺したくもないし それでも殺しちまっちゃうというならば
それなりのなんかまあわけがあるんですね
ですから 殺人は殺人ですけど
まあまあ普通の殺人よりはちょっとカルマが違うかなと思います
子供よっぽど運が悪いです
その場合はね だから自分には全く業として合ってないところに生まれちゃうんだからね
母親と子供っていうのは
いくらかどこかで業の世界で合ってないとうまくいかないんですね
性格が合ってないと 全く母親に嫌われる性格で生まれちゃうと
もうよっぽど運が悪いというか
これ生まれてくる人の問題なんですね
まあそういうわけでも
そんなに世の中で見られる現象ではないんです
この銃後っていうのは
例えば瞑想する人々はもうみんなすごい禅定なんか作るかというと
それでもないんですね
それでちゃんと正しく瞑想禅定なんか作れる方法もほとんどないし
全部世の中にある瞑想っていうのは
もうまず現象を作ってイメージを作って
このイメージなんか安置させたりして
なんとかちょっと心おかしくするだけのことの方がものすごい多いし
そこでちゃんとした心理学的に見て
きちんとした心を育てたと次元が乗り越えたと
違う次元で物を見えるようになったということは
もうそんな科学的にやってないんですから
この禅定を作るということも
世の中でそんなにあるわけじゃないんです
結構少ないんですね まあそこで
だから人が亡くなったらガルカマがないと
ガルカマない場合はアーサンナカマが機能しちゃうんですね
アーサンナっていうのは近豪ですね
いわゆる近いということで
一番この最近 最近やったことを結果が出すんです
あまり難しくないんです
人が死ぬ時 どんなカルマで次に生まれ変わるかというと
もう最近何をやったんですかと
この最近したことが影響を与えちゃうんですね
だから我々の心のインパクトから見ると
やっぱり一番最近やったことのインパクトの方が強いでしょ
ですから この死ぬ間際にした業があの結果出しちゃうんです
最近の業 まあそういうわけで
人が一生いいことをろくなことをしなかったかもしれませんだけど
まあ死ぬ時でも 私はもうそろそろ死ぬんだということを知った方が
なんとか将来は幸福にはなれるんです
ですから 死ぬということを最後まで言わないで騙す人々はもう
決まってるんですね まあまあ
そういうわけで 仏教ではいつでも人にはね
死ぬということはもう自分の身近な事実として
それに頭の中でなければいけませんと
それがなければ人がもうどうなるか分からないし
本当に亡くなってからいいところに生きたければ
自分がいつでも死ぬかもしれませんという
この死はいつでも一番身近な事実
死だけ身近な事実なんです
他のものはもう可能性だけ
確かではないんですね
何一つも確かではない
もう将来金持ちになるかというも確かじゃない
じゃあ破産するか どっちでも確かではない
死ぬまで健康的にいられるかないかというのも
一つも確かじゃない でも確かな事実っていうのは
一番身近な事実っていうのは
世の中で死ぬということなんですね
それはもうそうじゃない